My dad used to love your TV show.
We've watched every episode.
Always nice to meet a fan.
Well, we just had the one TV.
This is the worst day ever.
It's just a bunch of olives.
Hey look, are you free tonight?
What, like a date?
Or it'll be just an appointment.
I'm not sleeping with you, I don't know what you are after.
Look, you had a terrible day, you just said it.
Let me take you to a place you might have a nice time.
Isn't it adorable when celebrities bring their hookers to the club?
Jackie Burke's in the crowd!
After everything I've done for you...
...I was there for you when you were starting out as a young man.
That was amazing, I feel like I'm high!
Do you come up with all that on the spot?
Hmm... Sometimes, yeah.
That was good, thank you.
I wanna know what your expectations are here.
My expectations?
When you look at my daughter and the way she's looking at you...
I'm not looking at him, what are you talking about?
You have three offers for appearances.
What's it gonna be?
Go out there, big shot. They want you.
No, this isn't your crowd.
You're a dancer?
Yeah.
You're viral again, over three million views in eight hours and it is still climbing.
You are on Kimmel, you're on Fallon.
Ladies and gentlemen, Jackie Burke.